this is the most indulgent thing i've
ever had oh my god
hey guys this is inca so last time my
friend a day
challenged me to mix as many fruits as
he could possibly find
to make it into this amazing fruit pie
before that he also asked me to mix
every cookie mix i could possibly find
every cake mix and every cereal but this
time
he actually got an idea from one of you
guys who suggested that i mix
every chip i could possibly find
together
so i was thinking i could crush all
these chips together and just taste them
like that but i also think that's not
very interesting so
you know how there's some restaurants
that's doing like hot cheeto crust
items i was thinking i could find all
these chips
crush them and make it into this like
breadcrumb situation
so then i could make mozzarella sticks
so that's what i'm gonna be doing today
mozzarella cheese steaks using every
chip i could possibly find
before we get started today i just
wanted to share that this video is
brought to you by skillshare
as most of you know i love sharing new
discoveries
and learnings with all of you and i get
a lot of questions a lot from you guys
about you know how to develop basic
cooking skills
how to take the best food photos well i
think skillshare is one of the best
resources out there
for you to start developing those skills
they have a huge variety of classes
there's this really awesome food
photography one by daniel krieger i'm
taking some food illustration ones
myself and it's been
pretty awesome the best thing is the
first 1000 people to click the link in
the description box below
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium membership
so i really encourage you all to give it
a try but all right with that being said
let's get back to business normally at
this part a day likes like throwing
items at me
from behind the camera but this time we
have
like what was it 80 something bags of
chips
i don't think i can carry all that in my
arm so
we're just gonna show you what we have
on the table look at that
isn't that crazy 81 different types of
chips in here
my game plan is to set up different
categories a spicy section
a sweet section a healthy category a
savory
cheesy and also a unique section
and we're going to bash them let's start
with category number one
cheesy doesn't sound like a call
first one we have is a zesty cheddar it
does smell a lot like cheddar
pretty orangey looking chips so
probably gonna add some color second
chip is cheddar and sour cream
it's a lighter orange compared to the
other one next up our cheetos
are cheetos really chips i feel like
it's hard to talk about chips
and not include cheetos because they're
such like a fan favorite
a cheddar jalapeno still mostly very
cheesy smelling halloween is just around
the corner right and we found this bag
of bones which i thought was
fun looking oh this is really good i
like this more than regular cheetos
popcorners very crunchy it's going to be
great for the texture
can't talk about cheese without talking
doritos there's a lot of flavor going in
there burritos
chili cheese ooh the cheddar is a little
that strong but the color is definitely
there
aged cheddar horseradish sounds really
fancy
these like wasabi cheese chips very
interesting maybe this should have gone
into unique sections
it's not bad if i say cheetos as a chip
this is also a chip
so a new york cheddar i don't know
how that is more special than usual
better but
it's not like a bright cheddar like the
orange cheeto
flavor it's not like a subtle white
cheddar flavor either
it's like somewhere in the middle
pringles cheddar and sour cream
pringles is such a classic cheese
section is all in let's move on to
spicy i feel like in this country we
love
our spice in our chips i mean flaming
hot is a huge thing right
flaming hot with like a huge fire sign
this is gonna look great i feel like
it's not that spicy
maybe that's just me i feel like the
spice is like kind of like at the back
slowly gets cheap yeah i feel it now
okay cool two flaming hot cheetos
one is flaming hot crunchy one is
flaming hot
lemon whoa it is super pigmented
love it when spice actually looks like
scary spicy
flaming hot again lime flavored
takis fuego this was the doritos from
earlier this
is takis
[Music]
all right another flaming hot this is
bunions
the flaming hot never ends next up we
have jalapeno flavored things i feel
like i'm gonna see this in all of them
but the specks of green
extra hot chili and lime and this one is
a sweet and spicy barbecue so we get a
bit of
zestiness bit of sweetness bit of
spiciness
doritos spicy sweet chili buffalo
blue oh i feel like it's hotter than the
flaming hot ones
these are very small chips i'm gonna do
two of them
not just because i like it also from
keto um
pepperoncini not as spicy as that ooh
hot and spicy potato chips from colby i
love healthy potato chips grew up on
them so the flavor of
childhood still quite a ways to go let's
move on to the next category
savory chips so there's a lot of
original flavors sea salt flavors
sour cream and onion i've also put in
this category but we're going to start
off with
tortilla chips just your regular good
old flavor
i like to think that this section is a
section where we neutralize all those
crazy flavors we just added
original flavor and salt and vinegar
flavor
sea salt and vinegar these are one of my
favorite chips
a big lay's classic did i ever mention
that i
went to an idaho so me and potatoes
we're good friends america's number one
finger hats
some pop chips unbelievably unfried
they're baked keto cooked sea salt
and cracked pepper next up i'm doing
some shrimp flavored chips
this is so good it has that sort of like
umami flavor oh
i smell it smells like the ocean but it
tastes like fish
in a nice way there's also mushroom
powder in this
another barbecue this one is backyard
barbecue
i sold this brand when i was in new
orleans this one is cajun
dill gator taters
taste faintly of pickles even though
there's no pickle flavoring at the back
here
potato skin snacks bacon ranch
it has more of a body to it this potato
chip
actually comes in the form of a fry
isn't that interesting rosemary and
olive oil which again
sounds very fancy so this is what we
have right now
maybe i was a little bit too careful so
i'm gonna actually go back really quick
and add one more chip of each flavor so
far into this bowl
before we move on to the sweet section
so next time you see me this bowl is
gonna be a lot bigger
a lot more chips in here now sweet chips
probably my favorite category i'm a big
sweet person i love making sweet things
i feel like that's pretty obvious i have
a big
big sweet tooth apple chips kind of
bizarre i know
but a little bit of sweetness brings out
the savory
taste of things because it's not as
crunchy anymore so i'm gonna cut it
sweet potato puffs this is what they
look like smells like a sweet potato
casserole
marshmallow is included it's very sweet
smelling i have sweet chili and i also
have sweet and salty kettle corn
we have some honey dijon my go-to salad
dressing and
occasionally dipping sauce so it has to
be good
honey butter chips it's probably one of
the best chips of all time
i can't there's no words it's like
smelling honey cake but it's savory
honey barbecue flavor twist it's like
flavor
right in the face it is very jam-packed
with flavor
here's an interesting one chocolate sea
salt coconut chips
yes we are making mozzarella sticks with
chocolate coconut chips
and it's going to be great i don't know
it might be really really bad but
so it's not exactly like a chip chip
very crunchy
it is a fruit chip after all so that's
kind of more like the texture as opposed
to like a root vegetable chip
i found these chips called inka chips
kinda like me plantain chips
this is very good it's super super
crunchy we have two more categories to
go
we are now in healthy chips flavored
with healthier things veggie straws here
and
this really cool packaged veggie chip
that i just found tomato powder
spinach powder beetroot powder green pea
snack crisps
the crunch in these are unbelievable
keto potato chips but they are flavored
with wild mushroom
it tastes very very faintly of mushrooms
sun chips i feel like are also known for
being like the healthier alternative
because of it being a 100 whole grain
never had rye chips before but i love
rye bread
oh these are like the i lied i've
totally had these before these are in
like the snack mix
yeah wow i didn't know this existed bean
chips
black beans and brown rice these ones
are made with black beans and navy beans
two more inca chips one is garlic flavor
one is
chili flavor salad chips another root
vegetable
also known as yucca super thin and
crispy if you can see
that's all for health last category
unique chips
things that fall under this category are
basically flavors that i feel like
are not as well known guinness flavored
potato chips oh yeah this looks like a
freshly made chip
it does taste like beer i don't want to
say bitter but it does have like you
know that like aftertaste of beer when
you drink it
it's almost like a richer flavor at the
back of your throat really nice
pizza flavor just from smelling it alone
it smells i guess like
tomato sauce with garlic and onion and
maybe that's
pizza but that's going in this one's
actually dill pickle flavored
it smells like a burger it smells like
pickles
you know how like pickle juice has that
sort of like acidic quality to it
wow this is so interesting lime
by itself color is pretty normal
it's like lime candy mixed with potato
chips
i'm a little confused healthy
another favorite this one is seaweed and
salt
then i have more shrimp chips yuzu and
black pepper flavored
i don't taste or smell too much of the
yuzu more keto chips i have dill pickle
and korean barbecue
korean rice cake flavored chips it has a
lot of red chili paste in this
i've had it and it kind of burns your
throat a little bit but it's very very
sweet and very very nice
very crunchy corn chips here one is just
a grilled corn flavored corn chip the
other one is a sweet corn flavor
puff okay last but not least you guys
we've made it to the very end
palm chips it's very savory
it's almost like borderline salty adding
some cheese to your
breading is a great way to elevate
whatever you're deep frying
here we have it 81 different types of
chips in here
time for me to do some crushing oh
this isn't even asmr anymore it's just
painful
i feel like there's only so much i can
do with this i'm gonna put in a ziploc
bag
and bash it
i think this is looking pretty good it
does have more of like a reddish
orange tinge now with like specks of
black and green and white
cheers
texture wise the potato chips
melted fairly quickly i think the corn
chip textures or the tortilla corn
tortilla textures
are the ones that lingered so they were
slightly chewier
flavor-wise primarily
savory which is very salty not so much
spice i wasn't getting spicy anymore i
feel like i did get some umami from the
cheese so there's definitely
some cheesy flavor in there and then i
think like
like vinegary aftertaste at the very end
the smell right now smells like barbecue
cheddar
now that i have my hand processed bread
crumb mixture
we can move on to the next segment so
now i have my breading station here
i have some mozzarella cheese here and
then i
made two of these monstrosities because
it's fun
so we're gonna dust this in the flour
egg wash
ultimate moment we're going to put it on
the chips
and just make it rain on top
press it in as much as i can the egg
mixture
just repeat that process another trick
that i learned from my gordon ramsay
recipe video
i am going to just press it in with this
wax paper
like that and there you go mozzarella
cheese stick
this is what we originally started with
and this is what it looks like now so
there's
a lot of great coating going on here
here
are all my little mozzarella stick
babies i say little but it's really not
that
little these are huge these are gigantic
now the next step is to freeze them
before we fry it so i'm gonna pop these
in the freezer
all right we are back these have been
resting in the freezer for i think
around 30 minutes probably a little bit
over
pretty firm right now which is what we
want so
i also have my air fryer here it's been
preheated so it's kind of hot
i'm gonna spray these first now spray
this
too and the last one in
this should take around five to six
minutes i'm gonna put it on 390.
[Music]
oh no it exploded
oh man look at that it looks so good
okay can you see how crispy it is i'm
smelling corn whether that's from the
corn
tortilla or the corn flavored chips with
like a bit of sweetness to it okay
oh boy look at that
oh it's gonna melt
texture-wise crunchy not as crunchy as i
thought it would be
but it's definitely there's definitely
like a crisp to it and it's like
slightly chewy again i feel like it's
from like the tortilla
chip texture you know how when you bite
into it it kind of like
lingers doesn't just melt in your mouth
all of this
is the crust this is like an 81 chip
crust
together it works so well hold on i'm
just gonna eat
literally just the skin here i was
expecting like this overwhelming
sensation of flavor
but it's kind of when you put it with
the cheese it becomes a lot more subtle
all the flavors again just blend into
one and it's
this perfect balance of like savory and
sweet my
mega muzz stick is done
this is the most indulgent thing i've
ever had oh my god
thank you guys so much for watching this
and thank you to all of those who
suggested that we
do this crazy chip combination keep
letting us know
what else you want to see us mix
together and we will see you guys next
time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you